la trace du cloud il ya un ange alors il
faudra gratter en dessous oui on imagine
l'autre mais on est on en voit d'autres
et du coup il ya encore toute une partie
du dessin qu'il faut retrouver une
peinture du christ en majesté les bras
ouverts avec des enjeux autour de lui et
sous un ciel étoilé c'est une image du
christ qui date de l'époque romane ou
c'était le christ sauveur très fort et
donc un témoignage particulièrement
anciens de la décoration d'origine de
cette église qui allaient à l'époque
était une église romane lié à l'abbaye
saint denis c'est l'heure de récents
travaux de rénovation de l'église saint
laurent que cette peinture a été
découverte dans les combles l'histoire
de cette oeuvre remontrer au 12e siècle
elle a sans doute été peintes lors de la
construction de l'église
l'édifice est alors lié à l'abbaye de
saint denis par un porche qui n'existe
plus aujourd'hui
le destin de la peinture bascule au 19e
siècle lorsqu'on modifie l'église pour
créer l'actuel voûte néogothique la
peinture tombe alors dans l'oubli
ça a un intérêt parce que les peintures
romane il y en a en réalité très peu qui
ont survécu jusqu'à nous et c'est
toujours un témoignage de l'imaginaire
du moyen-âge qui est particulièrement
rare puisqu'il ne reste extrêmement peu
d'exemples de fresques romanes en france
en tout cas de cette époque on peut
supposer que d'autres fresques murales
ont été peintes dans le choeur de
l'église peut-être sont-elles caché sous
une couche de chaux reste à mener
quelques investigations à la recherche
d'autres trésors picturaux